making his way through he's maverick
McNeely and first time that we've had a
chance to cross paths with you got an
interesting background here and you know
your dad family brothers and here you
are
Pebble Beach pro-am how do you feel it's
pretty fun last time I was here I was
caddying for my dad about four years ago
so it's fun to be flying this time when
did when did you become more famous than
you dad I think that started when my dad
started introducing himself as Mavs dad
I was a couple and he likes to call
himself formally famous and important
like I don't buy it but he was what did
he start Sun Microsystems and okay now
do you know anything about that or what
your dad was doing to become famous
before you became famous uh not really I
was pretty young I was pretty young when
he sold the company probably around 12
or 13 say and but you know I've actually
spent more time with his startup
weighing I actually interned there for a
couple weeks over a couple of summers
before college and a lot more familiar
with that and I've also done some work
for his startup crickey so more more
familiar with those in Sun Microsystems
even when did you start playing golf
I can't remember not playing I think my
dad put a little plastic Club in my
hands soon as I could walk and I just
started hitting things do you think if
you started at 13 14 15 you'd be here
well maybe I think I played a ton of
sports growing up I played ice hockey
through my senior year of high school so
I was a two-sport athlete till I went to
college and I played basketball soccer
tennis I swam a little bit so I I really
only started focusing on golf seriously
in college so I I think that's the way
to go honestly when did you know you
were good my dad told me that I have a
little I have an uncanny knack for the
game I remember that we were playing the
the dunes course at Monterey Peninsula
and I must have been seven or eight and
he said I have an uncanny knack for the
game but I was seven and still aiming at
cart path because that was a way to
double the driving distance but I mean
III think it was my fresh my sophomore
year started my sophomore year Cameron
and Patrick Rodgers Cameron Wilson
Patrick Rodgers just graduated I
playing number one on the team so
nervous I and I thought someone had to
fill that role
and I ended up making seven threes in a
row in the final round of the first
college event that year in one and just
kind of fell into being somewhat decent
at golf it just kind of caught me by
surprise to be honest what was that oh
my gosh moment where you're playing with
somebody famous have you had that gun
it's it's more when I walk into player
dining and I say that's a guy I've seen
on TV a thousand times and now he's
actually here in person I remember when
I qualified for the US Open at Pinehurst
I was 18 years old and I my dad was
caddying for me there and we went into
player dining and dad goes man look it's
Bubba Watson but it's all fun
the name everett came from what my dad
jokes that my mom had a crush on Tom
Cruise but in all actuality my 300
brothers yeah where's goose right but in
all actuality my three younger brothers
and I are all named after American cars
my dad grew up in Detroit and my grandpa
worked in the auto industry so maverick
I think it's a Ford Dakota is a Dodge
pickup truck colt is also a Ford or is
that he's all he's a Dodge and Scout is
a Jeep Scout yeah but couldn't you have
maybe after nicer cars yeah well mines
cool like Porsche or like the colt is
ugly but ya know hi I got a good one do
you make fun of your brothers because of
their names with the cars
I don't you ask I just don't know how
I'm gonna top that I might just go with
like Joe and Bob and Fred I I've got no
chance no and and I like that there's
rules with dad had forward no tattoos no
piercings is that right yeah dad says
yeah he has plenty of one-liners about
that but like well what would your dad
do if Seton was was your company yeah if
your dad saw what cheating's got there
with his gun too my dad would would say
he's never seen a bumper sticker on a
Ferrari that's his that's his most
recent Wow
no but it's you know pants up pat
forward Chuck Taylors yeah it's more
because
scared of my mom then my dad and so no
that's pretty cool though that it's nice
let's say you won Augusta would and you
said dad if I win Augusta can I get a
tattoo
I hear they hurt ya oh it's also okay no
I don't want to the partnership with
Calloway how did that come about that
one is I was pretty easy to be
completely honest right I was all Nike
through college Stanford is a Nike
School and I played all their equipment
and my senior year they announced
they're getting out of the club industry
or the golf club you know making end I
toured Callaway tailor-made and Titleist
best summer before my senior spring and
what really did it for me is walking
through the entire Callaway R&D process
they took me through the whole tour
showed me how clubs were made start to
finish golf ball everything and I walked
out of there thinking this is a group of
guys that a group of engineers that are
working really hard to nitpick
everything they can to make the golf
club better and I thought I want to be
playing their stuff in three four years
because I see what they're putting into
it now that chess Center is great yeah
I brought these Falls down there yeah
they just I think they just replaced all
the turf that we took up when when we
were down there it did just redo it no
yeah it's because of these guys right
there if I have you back in ten years
what are we talking about hopefully some
good golf along the way
hopefully some other cool stuff that
I've been able to do off the golf course
cuz my dad always tells us to whom much
is given much is expected and I it's
it's no secret that I have a lot of
amazing opportunities that you know not
many have and I think it's my job to do
everything I can to do something good
with that I'm I'm not sure how that is
right now and right now I'm just worried
about getting that first tee shot in the
fairway and trying to get status and and
play good golf but I think there's a lot
of amazing golfers and a lot of and the
PGA Tour organization itself is does
some really amazing things I think
there's a stat they're saying that that
the PGA Tour donates annually more to
charity than the NHL and MLB NBA and NFL
combined so I think it's a great sport
to do good and that's what I'd love to
do in 10 years but you didn't have your
own bedroom girl
no no if the there were four beds lined
up so you and your brothers had we're on
the same room
yeah there's four of us it was nice the
beds were close enough together that one
colt the one you slept next to me was
snoring I could grab the pillow from
behind my head whack him go back and
like I was asleep and you wouldn't even
know hey good luck and it's nice - nice
to meet you with everything with your
background and certainly got a bright
future there but thanks for joining us
we appreciate it thanks for having me
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at